okay here we are in overtime I thought
before I started with the questions we
might get if you wanted to a rebuttal of
our editorial there about Americans
really being closeted socialists from
well let me yeah let me quote Margaret
Thatcher the problem with socialism is
that eventually you run out of other
people's money and the difference
between Europe and America and why
America is so great is that Europe has
haves and have-nots you have rich people
they probably you have rich people that
have been rich for ten generations and
you have poor people that can't get a
job they're not allowed actually social
mobility which is the ability of one
generation to do better than the last
one we are tenth in the world we are
behind there a number of European
countries but America is different
because anybody can do anything in this
country nobody tells you what you can do
and what in Belgium that doesn't you
know this idea that America this
American exceptionalism tell me where in
those countries I know in some countries
of course we're not talking about
Somalia but in Western European nations
you you can't do whatever you want I'm
talking about France where the union's
don't let young Muslim kids get jobs and
instead you get riots in the street
there's no opportunity there has to be
growth well it has to be I I would never
say that there is nothing wrong with
Europe of course there are problems in
Europe too I'm just but first of all
that was not even addressing this point
earlier not complete but that editorial
was saying that Americans are hypocrites
because they hate the word socialism but
they constantly take money from the
government and use socialist programs
including people like Michele Bachmann
farm subsidies Medicare Fannie Mae and
Freddie Mac what what why is she not a
hypocrite well let's talk about Medicare
Medicare is a program that everybody is
forced to join when their night when
they're 65 right so what happens if you
want to buy health insurance outside of
Medicare when you're 66 the doctor is
punished and you get you don't get the
services that you want because there's
no market for seniors health care this
is a funny guy with the sign with the
guy with the sign is basically saying
you forced me into this program and now
you're saying that you're going to take
half a trillion dollars out of Medicare
and put it into Obamacare grow the
population and create a ration system
where less people get the health care
they not gonna get that's the modern
Matt yeah I hate to you look you're
fundamentally wrong about so many things
you're saying here you don't even know
where to start
[Applause]
Medicare works Medicare is efficient the
driver of health care cost is not
limited to Medicare it has completely -
agree this problem - you know it has
completely different structural reasons
Medicare has been a remarkable program
income inequality has gone up since the
Reagan deregulatory policies went into
place job growth has gone down Europe
has surpassed us what Bill is saying is
exactly right some sort of melding of
the theology that you embrace that it is
all the private sector and some notion
that the public sector creates wealth is
obviously where you have to go but you
guys are ideologues who don't appreciate
that what are you gonna do with the
unfunded liabilities in these programs
the numbers simply don't work and the
only way that you solve that problem is
by rationing Matt's care that if you had
been listening to what many people are
now I'm just one of many voices have
been saying we have been saying very
sensible things about changing Medicare
Medicaid I changed Medicaid in New York
State I did it I didn't say let's just
lower taxes I said let's change health
care delivery and we did it we didn't
wrap ourselves in the flag of lower
taxes is the only answer you guys are
just one note Charlie's ok
let's go to the questions from the
internet why shouldn't we Institute a
luxury tax on non essential goods and
services such as boats jewelry and
gambling like we had in the 90s we had
luxury taxes in the 90s and it we saw is
that in specific industries after not
just not just noticing that sales went
down in those industries and people
stopped buying those there is actually
in the corporate jet
there's Learjet actually there was there
was a tax levied against people who are
buying Lear Jets sales went down
tremendously they went around and
questioned all the buyers why did you
not buy them it was the luxury tax
luxury tax distance disincentivizes
purchases and then it decreases jobs so
if you I mean if you if you want to
actually affect the it hurt the economy
luxury taxes are not the way to grow an
economy to help businesses be able to
invest grow create jobs but it does it's
a little counterintuitive cuz it doesn't
seem like the kind of people who would
be buying a corporate jet would be like
on a budget they are the country that is
so not true and they do create some jobs
but you know this idea that when we give
them the money as we've been doing for
30 years what they will do with it is
create jobs of course they don't they
themselves gonna give you different
reason why it doesn't make sense
yes it's the real problem it's not going
to generate enough revenue now if you
really want to change the tax code what
we should do is repeal the Bush tax cuts
for the wealthy what across the board
don't just do it for
tax isn't taxing the wealthy because the
top 1% pay 38% of the tax share right
sure
so that income did again and that that
top 1% of the income do they get that
answer I don't know but here you take
that top 1% in 2008 you tax all of the
taxable income that they can have you
generate 938 billion dollars the deficit
in 2008 is 1.6 trillion dollars let me
just ask what we got to go I'll just has
one basic question it's on this topic
was this a better country when the rich
paid more and the rich used to pay a lot
more like in the 50s and 93 over 90
percent right that's too much but wasn't
it a better really well I think that but
even that was not enough to drive you to
out of the country marginal tax rate
when you when your great-grandfather was
president well it actually went up from
25% to 66% because also your
great-grandfather 66% marginal rate
raise taxes are conservative slam
imagine I know but was it a better
country yes wasn't it a better country
wasn't there a more thriving middle
class yeah I mean is that is it is it
complete in the last 30 years we've seen
from Reagan onward including Clinton
we've seen this giant transference of
wealth to the top one percent they used
to have 8 percent of the pie now they
have almost 25 percent of the pie wasn't
the country a better place for everybody
when that money and that is a lot of
money was more distributed through
society yes
[Applause]
give up my cars but I would I would
certainly pay a lot more in taxes we
should legalize marijuana and
prostitution
[Applause]